what we're going to do in this video is
talk about the notion of equilibrium in
a macroeconomics context so let's review
a little bit of what we've already
studied about aggregate demand and
aggregate supply so this vertical axis
here that is the price level for the
economy that we are trying to study and
this horizontal axis right over here
this would be the real GDP for that
economy the real g.d.p and now I could
draw an aggregate demand curve in
previous videos we've talked at length
why economists like to model it as a
downward sloping curve but once again
take all of these things with a grain of
salt there's a lot of assumptions break
baked in and then I can also draw
aggregate supply aggregate supply and
this would be short-run aggregate supply
upward sloping curve so I'll just call
that short-run aggregate supply and I'll
call that short-run aggregate supply one
because we might look at other potential
aggregate supply curves I could also
look at other potential aggregate demand
curves but let's just do that for now so
given these curves what would be the
price level and the level of output for
this economy pause this video and think
about it well some of y'all might just
very naturally say well it would be the
output in the price level that
corresponds to this point of
intersection and if you said that you
would be correct so this would be our
short-run equilibrium output let me
label that so that right over there is
our short-run equilibrium equilibrium
equilibrium output corresponds to where
the short-run aggregate supply
intersects to the aggregate demand curve
and then this right over here would be
our equilibrium price level let's call
that PL 1 now why do we feel good that
this would be the short-run equilibrium
output and this would be the price level
well let's imagine what would happen if
we were at a lower price level let's say
right over here at that price level we
see that aggregate demand is
outstripping aggregate supply the output
that added that the
demand wants is much higher than the
output of the aggregate the short-run
aggregate supply and so that would be a
shortage situation there's not enough
output for all of that demand and what
would likely happen in that situation
well the the folks producing that output
would probably say hey I'm gonna charge
a little bit more for my output and as
they're charging more they'll say maybe
I also produce a little bit more output
and they'll move up the curve towards
that equilibrium point and then on the
demand side people would say hey I'm not
getting the output I need I'm willing to
pay more for it but as the cost of that
output also goes up the demand the
output demanded would go down and we end
up back at that equilibrium point and we
could do the same thought exercise if
for some reason we were at a price level
above PL 1 in this situation aggregate
supply short-run aggregate supply is a
good bit higher than aggregate demand
and so you have more output than what is
being demanded and so what's likely to
happen
well the suppliers the people producing
the output will say well I'm gonna
charge a little bit less for my output
and produce less and then similarly
those demanding will say hey there's
this glut of output I'm gonna pay less
for that output but as they're able to
pay less for it they'll say hey I want
more and more of it and we get back to
the equilibrium point now what we've
talked about so far is in the short-run
but some of you might be saying well
what about the long-run and in previous
videos we have talked about long-run
aggregate supply and so let's say that
this curve right over here represents
the long-run aggregate supply curve and
where it intersects the horizontal axis
this y sub F you could view this as the
output of this economy at full
employment and it's really the
sustainable output of this economy at
full employment and so what's going on
in the graph right over here our
equilibrium output is what our short-run
equilibrium output is below our full
employment output and so we have a gap
so there's a negative to go from our
full employment output to our
equilibrium output and so if we
want to think about this in the context
of the business cycle where would we be
on it so let's draw the business cycle
so now I'll make the vertical axis the
level of real output so this would be
real GDP right over here and then on the
horizontal axis this will be the passage
of time that is time and so what
typically so at any given point in time
there will be a y sub F there will be
some sustainable potential output for
that economy and when I say sustainable
it means you know people are sleeping
properly resting properly you're not
unsustainably depleting resources and so
for example at this point in time that
might be the Y sub F and that may be a
few years later may be the population
has grown there's more infrastructure
technology has improved so now they can
sustainably produce more and then a few
years after that maybe they could
produce even more population growth
they've they've think thought about
better ways to arrange the resources and
the economy technology improves and so
you could imagine a world where that
full employment output could just grow
in a very nice way like this or it could
just grow nicely like this but we know
that's not the way real economies work
they experience the business cycle and
the business cycle looks more like this
so it will look more like this where you
have your peaks and these troughs a boom
and bust cycles sometimes people will
talk about it and the parts of this
curve where you have increasing real GDP
like there or there or there we would
call those expansions so that is
economic expansion and the parts where
GDP is receding so for example right
over here right over here we would call
those recessions or recessions but let's
go back to our aggregate demand and
aggregate supply world right over here
this equilibrium point y sub 1 what
point could that correspond to on this
on this graph right
here of the business cycle and let me
label that this is the business the
business cycle
what pause this video think about what
point it could correspond to - well
we're at a point where our short-run
equilibrium output is below our full
employment output our potential output
our sustainable full potential output so
this would correspond to some point
where our real GDP is sitting below this
blue curve or this blue line the way
I've drawn it and so y sub one could for
example be this point or it could be
that point or it could be that point and
so if it was this one right over here
then that right over there would be Y
sub one and and this right over here
would be the Y sub F would be the Y sub
F for this point in time now as we go
forward in time this y sub F we see this
economic growth it could move to the
right as population grows as we have
better technology etc etc etc but you're
probably thinking well what about other
points are that can we are there others
possible scenarios and my answer to you
would be absolutely so you could imagine
a world where the equilibrium output is
to the right of our potential output and
I will construct that by making a
different short-run aggregate supply
curve although I could also do that by
shifting the aggregate demand curve and
we'll do that in future videos but
imagine a situation like this imagine so
I'll call this short-run aggregate
supply - and now this is our equilibrium
equilibrium output y sub 2 and it
corresponds to price level price level 2
right over here and notice here there's
a gap but it's a positive gap we our
actual output is above our sustainable
output and so for example this could
correspond to maybe at this point if it
does correspond to this point so if this
was Y sub 2 then this would be our
current Y sub F I didn't actually shift
it but hopefully you're getting the
general idea and you're saying well how
can you produce beyond full employment
how can you
reduce beyond your sustainable potential
well this is an economy that is
producing output in an unsustainable way
unemployment is unusually low you have
maybe depleting resources people are
working too hard they're getting
stressed out they're not sleeping
properly however you want to think about
it it's not considered sustainable and
then you have a third scenario where
your short-run equilibrium output
actually equals your full employment
output and so that could be this
scenario right over here so this would
be our short-run aggregate supply three
and notice over here our equilibrium
output y sub three is equal to our full
employment output and when this happens
this is considered a long-run
equilibrium so let me write that down
that is considered a long-run
equilibrium equilibria and points that
correspond to long-run equilibria on
this business cycle right over here
would be this point right over there
that point at that point and at that
point so I'll leave you there in future
videos we will actually think about how
aggregate demand and short-run aggregate
supply will shift and connect it even
further to the cycles in the business
cycle